la Cour supérieure du Québec a accepté
d'entendre l'action collective qui a été
intentée par des parents d'enfants
mineurs contre Epic Games si Epic Games
ça vous dit rien vous risquez plutôt de
connaître le mot le nom fortnite ça
c'est le jeu que l'entreprise a
développé et commercialisé et ce jeu
rejoint tenez-vous bien à peu près 250
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
alors pour mieux comprendre le recours
en activité
spécialisée en droit civile bonjour
Guylaine alors qu'est-ce que les
demandeurs vont devoir démontrer le
d'abord d'abord ils vont devoir le
montrer que ce jeu là il est dangereux
et ça ça nous mène tout de suite est-ce
que ça peut créer de la dépendance quand
on lit les procédures et même le
jugement on voit qu'ils vont provinces
basées
mondial de la santé dit que c'est un
trouble c'est une maladie ensuite ils
vont
ils vont assez fort ils disent que c'est
une dépendance qui ressemble à la
cocaïne
absolument c'est très accoutumant parce
qu'ils vont démontrer c'est que le
cerveau des enfants c'est plus
vulnérable c'est pas encore mature et
ils ont pas un sens d'auto-protection
alors il jouit et quand on lit ce que
les enfants vécu entre ceux qui font
partie de la procédure c'est vraiment
troublant Isabelle d'ailleurs il
faudrait qu'ils démontre que tout ça a
été fait de façon
volontaire que les personnes qui ont
développé ce jeu là l'ont fait sciemment
en essayant de provoquer cette
cyberdépendance tout à fait ils disent
qu'il y a des psychologues qui ont
travaillé sur le jeu pour que ça
devienne très très accoutumant justement
et qui a même des tactiques qui
ressemblent aux machines à sous pour
qu'on revienne tout le temps donc ça il
va devoir également ce dont on vient de
parler prouver ça qu'il savait et qui
aurait dû avertir de ces risques là
surtout et finalement le dernier truc de
peut-être pas familial avec le jeu mon
Lotus des neveux qui jouent alors on
peut acheter des v-bucks c'est comme des
privilèges parce qu'un gratuit mais on
peut dépenser pour ajouter un costume
une musique une arme parce qu'un jeu de
tir et d'élimination et c'est des
mineurs ils achètent ça et on peut payer
directement avec son petit compte de
banque et à ce moment-là on va avoir à
discuter sur lésions au code civil nous
dans une phrase à lésion c'est si un
jeune contracte un achat qui est hors de
ses moyens on peut annuler j'ai 200
dollars en banque et j'achète un scooter
de 6000 dollars on peut annuler fait que
ça ils vont devoir prouver qu'il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle nous Andros civil
lésions bon j'allais justement vous
demander à quelle loi cette entreprise
contrevient la Epic Games vous me parlez
du Code civil mais il y en a sûrement
des d'autres lois tout à fait protection
du consommateur parce qu'on doit aviser
des risques un petit peu des notions de
vice cachée aussi même c'est un jeu là
ça ressemble à certains objets puis va
voir la charte atteint l'intégrité à la
vie parce que il y a des séquelles assez
graves chez certains de problèmes
physiques et psychologique déjà des
jeunes qui deviennent très très
agressifs des parents qui ont tenté
d'arrêter le jeu et ça fonctionne pas il
y a même des centres un peu j'appellerai
de désintoxication de ce jeu là qui
existe dans le monde bon alors justement
vous avez parlé des parents est-ce que
les parents pourraient être tenus
d'assumer un peu une responsabilité
parce que ils auraient pas je sais pas
moi interdit à leurs enfants de jouer à
ça c'est une bonne question on sent
d'ailleurs que ça va être discuter dans
le jugement on a on en parle et on voit
déjà ce que ça va discuter il plaidait
mais est-ce que les parents déjà
s'aiment comme piste c'est qu'ils
avaient pas l'impression à première vue
que ce jeu-là était si dangereux il y
avait un petit look and fil un peu rétro
il y a pas de sens
un petit côté cartoon
il l'aurait pas fait mais le contrôle
parental aussi dit c'est très difficile
parce que c'est surtout de plateforme on
lit dans une des requêtes le parent mais
me cadenas pour pas accéder où est
l'endroit où des fois c'est dans la
cuisine l'ordinateur ça c'est bémo mais
on peut aussi jouer exemple mais
concrets dans l'autobus en allant à la
polyvalence sur son cellulaire alors ça
va discuter jusqu'où les parents peuvent
avoir un contrôle je vais vous entendre
sur un autre aspect parce que une action
collective qui vise un jeu vidéo c'est
une première ça en Amérique du Nord ou
peut-être au monde je sais pas mais
est-ce que c'est une première et je
pense le monde entier va suivre
continuateurs que vous avez dit c'est
parce que dans les petites clauses qu'on
lit jamais qu'on accepte avant de jouer
à un jeu
tout à fait
ça dit qu'on renonce aux actions
collectives dans plusieurs juridictions
dans le monde nous on est le village
d'Astérix là au Québec parce que ça ne
peut pas s'appliquer à nous parce qu'on
a des lois de public qui disent que les
fabricants doivent nous informer de
risques tout ça donc les yeux vont
intriguer sur cette décision là pour
ailleurs d'ailleurs il y a eu un
règlement dans le monde mais concernait
les vibox là justement de l'argent
aux États-Unis mais pas le sur le côté
dépendant il nous reste à peu près 30
secondes alors il nous reste une minute
il me dit Karine alors on va pas passer
un autre registre complètement vous a
semé de regarder le une partie du
documentaire qui touche le prince le
prince Harry et Meghan Mako c'était
disponible aujourd'hui sur Netflix on
parlait de possibilité de poursuites
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose de
diffamatoire de ce que j'ai écouté
évidemment pour vous bien sûr parce que
ça vous intéresse
dans le premier épisode que j'ai écouté
qui raconte leur histoire d'amour mais
je sentais quand même le travail moi je
l'ai fait souvent sur des documentaires
qui avaient plusieurs avocats qui
étaient passés par là par exemple on va
dire que les médias sont trop agressifs
mon homme pas quel média et on donne des
images avec plein plein de de bannières
de médias sur les micros alors
identifier mais évidemment et après ça
s'il y a des choses diffamatoires qui
viennent dans les prochains épisodes ce
sera
étonnant que la couronne poursuive que
les royales poursuivent on dit qu'on a
sollicité leur opinion en début
d'émission et leur commentaire et ça
peut donner mais je vais les continuer
de l'écouter d'accord pour vous très
bien et je m'en référerai à vous merci
Ghislaine je vous en prie pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI